so Leslie asks if you've all voted have
a person
I hear there's still time to write in a
constitutional monarchy today is yet
young for that all right so um this is
the third time I've done this class and
it does keep growing the first time I
did this there was a small room with 12
people in it in seven of them were
Leslie's family members so you do keep
growing I'm I'm glad I'm glad that this
class keeps growing that
entrepreneurship and engineering alive
here at Stanford when I first started
presenting here I was part of the
cleantech open I was running this
organization actually for six years and
volunteered for two years before and I
am no longer representing Leslie the
cleantech open I'm actually out in the
real world doing real things with real
companies and i'm working with a clean
tech open company that i think has a lot
of potential but before I kind of carry
on I want to give you a small commercial
for the world's largest accelerator for
clean tech startups how many of you here
have a clean tech type project that
you're interested in becoming
entrepreneurs of yes I mean any of you
want to take care of your projects to
market I saw three very low hands all
right so yes you fix my own mission ice
911 was invited to be the first
nonprofit to participate in the
cleantech open and this was several
years ago I think 2013 and we became
semi-finalists even though we didn't fit
the model at all and I was telling Rex
but why would you imagine Leslie not
fitting a model man you did a great job
they always conform ah and and I was
telling Rex off offline but why on earth
not say it here this was one of the best
things we ever did for our projects so I
am a huge fan of the cleantech open and
I'm sorry i didn't mention no no no well
you know it's it's great to have that
commercial so as I say I'm no longer
representing link open I used to run the
organization but I do not anymore I'm
out doing things outside the the if you
like nonprofit and academic well
and I'm back into the space of working
with real companies who are really
trying to solve a real problem and the
irony behind the cleantech open is it
looks very different from a classic
nonprofit not normally nonprofit
organizations are there to serve
minority groups who have a need for some
kind of support but we support a
minority I guess entrepreneurs but we
support them in an unusual way the
organization supports entrepreneurs who
could save the planet as long as they
had access to the kind of help that's
required to become commercial successes
if any one of you were to find a new way
of producing in electrons or podia for
universities it would be a terrific
thing if you succeeded but it wouldn't
be a you know a huge train smash if you
failed and of course entrepreneurship
makes us all very humble because there's
a very high propensity to fail in
entrepreneurship and in clean tech
entrepreneurship and even greater
propensity which is why the cleantech
opens fat founders started this
model and the model was that we need to
find a way to provide commercial success
to build traction for companies that
could make a big difference and how do
we do that while we we deconstruct it if
you like the process of entrepreneurship
and much of what I'm going to talk about
this morning this afternoon is kind of
selection afternoon and I've got no idea
what that where I am but what much of
what I'm going to talk about this
afternoon is to do with what it takes to
take an engineering project if you like
and make it into a commercial success
okay so failure failure is much more
common entrepreneurship than we like
failure makes us humble probably humbles
out of word that's even legal in these
holes at Stanford but it makes us it
makes us very humble and i am now
connected to at least a thousand
companies and i have to take
responsibility for their failures too
all right another thing that makes me
very humble but I've learned a few
things and the truth is that that the
learning process is what teaches us to
do
things a bit differently from the way we
used to now the likes of Steve Blank
Alex austere Wilder aleck Reese have if
you like uncovered a new way of thinking
about entrepreneurship these names which
are meaningful to you guys Steve Blank
is is an amazing speaker and a professor
here in a Bennett Cal probably another
word I can't mention in Stanford and and
what he's done is to deconstruct the
process and build a methodology around
some he calls customer development Eric
Ries has taken agile development and
customer development putting together in
something called the Lean Startup
methodology and I am now in the bizarre
position that having taught these things
to entrepreneurs for some years and now
enacting these things so I'm being a
live entrepreneur with one particular
company which I'm very excited about in
the solar space and if Leslie invites me
back next year I'll tell you what I've
learned in that environment as well and
to use the the learning that I have
built up over the past 10 years or so
I'm going to boil these things down
quite quickly into these three different
areas it's appropriate that most of the
focus on entrepreneurship is put on the
first of these solve it should say a
core problem a major problem or meet a
need better than the available
alternatives is point number one and the
reason this is so important is because
many entrepreneurs deliver products into
the market that they think are terrific
we we have this conceit that because we
think something's amazing we believe
that other people will buy it and no
product without a market will ever reach
that stage I mentioned the beginning
which is the commercial traction
required to make a difference
commercially successful clean tech
products have a chance of solving our
biggest challenges those products that
remain inside the garage because the
entrepreneurs too concerned about his or
her IP which is a major problem there
are many phenomenal technologies which
never make much never see the light of
day because of this concern about
someone might steal my thing and those
that never make it commercially have no
chance of making a big impact there are
exceptions to every rule an exception
would be you could you could solve the
commercial problem by being a nonprofit
Leslie's talked about her experience of
doing that you could solve the
commercial problem by selling your
technology quote unquote to a government
you could find donors but but
classically speaking the things that
take off and the products that we
believe will make a difference meet the
rules of capitalism they have customers
and somebody buys them so the first
thing you need to do is you need to
solve a problem meet a need maybe that
the product is not something which is a
true pain point better than the
available alternatives the second thing
is you need to capture your customers
imagination and third thing is you need
to build trust now I put these these
three things up because they're the
combination that seals the deal if you
like it's very hard to sell somebody
something if it doesn't meet their
requirements if it doesn't solve their
problem if it's not something that they
that they you know truly want or truly
need now there are again exceptions you
can buy small consumer products but to
make a difference we need to have
products that that really meet a
customer's need to capture a customer's
imagination also important and we'll
explain a bit more about the imagination
process and how we inspire people and
thirdly developing trust particularly
when it comes to to corporations all
right so um the first of these things
I'll cover quickly and as I say just a
few minutes here to talk about what is a
huge amount of learning in a small
number of minutes these guys here Reese
and trout are
couple of guys who wrote books in the
80s marketing books and one of the big
lessons from the 22 immutable laws of
marketing is that you start bizarrely
with tactics and you then move on to
strategy it sounds upside down right
because you've all heard that in
strategic planning I think you believe
this the generals right build the street
the strategy first they have a strategic
umbrella and then they build a series of
tactics that sit underneath the strategy
and the the ground forces and the air
cover and the information and
misinformation that you produce the
marketing you do in the commercial
market the air cover you provide the
retail and all the other pieces will fit
underneath an umbrella strategy and the
truth is that many companies have
started with strategy and moved to
tactics and failed why do they fail
because they're not thinking about the
number one most important thing which
all of those three things I put up on
the screen a moment ago relate to the
customer we have to win Steve blanks
terms get out of the building we have to
find in Eric Reese's terms a quick way
to pivot if we don't find the customer
who's interested in our product and we
have to build we have to measure and we
have to learn build measure learn it's
an iterative cycle the iteration that we
talked about normally when working with
entrepreneurs is the idea creation
moving through customer validation then
moving into some kind of inspiration
some kind of learning which then moves
us through the cycle again so getting
out of the building testing little tiny
bits of a product making sure that we
don't build we don't engineer something
that nobody wants is a crucial way of
crucial way of building a business and
quite different from the way that we
traditionally thought about building
businesses
and 20 years ago okay there are other
things we can do this is called the
business model canvas this is a way of
if you like taking a business and
breaking it down into bite-sized chunks
and you'll see on here something which
is kind of the heart this whole thing
called a value proposition the value
prop is what's the product or service
that we are building and why might it be
attractive to put a particular customer
and then you'll see over in this top
corner over here you'll see a an area
called customer segments who's the
customer who's going to buy this thing
when we talk about customer segments we
talk about very little tiny pieces of
the market really sub-segments if we can
find a way of owning or dominating a
tiny tiny market a tiny homogeneous
market where the people within it looked
like each other and they sound like each
other and they have the same needs and
we can service all those needs of that
group of people we're far more likely to
build a successful company if we can
then find adjacent markets which are
similar to the first market we're far
more likely to be successful any ideas
and that is why why is it better to
build a product and dominate a small
market and to say everyone's my customer
because it sounds crazy right why not go
to big markets spread the word
absolutely we do incremental development
then you don't try to boil the ocean on
ah on your product apart which you
targeted in one area and then you can
expand it to another and incrementally
expand your product right so it's an
incremental growth strategy and then I
think you had a point so you have to
know what you are good at you should do
too many things you cannot figure out
what you don't realize very good well
you know spoken by a true entrepreneur a
true engineer right yes any other points
so you can build a successful company
when you grow it bit by bit you can
build a successful company when customer
number one has sim
needs to customer number two where
customer number one can say the customer
metoo i bought this thing it's good you
should take a look when customer number
two then comes to you it's the same
feature set as required by customer
number one a very quick way to kill a
company's have customer number one over
here who's the industrial packager and
customer of a number two over here who
is a consumer who just normally buys
products below two hundred dollars how
do you service their needs how do you
build a product that they both will
enjoy and then when you get customer
with three over here who's in a
different country with a completely
different set of requirements you find
and one of the fastest ways to failure
is you'll find that the customer service
requirements grow exponentially now
we're talking of course about technology
companies in particular yes you are able
to enter the market with the lean as
possible entry because you've understood
this particular customer well and you
know as you said your incrementally than
adding to that which is probably part of
this accessory right exactly right so
you can you can build that mean want to
get a call points which which I'll come
on to in a bit now maybe we'll just
cover it now is it is something called
pivot velocity which is kind which comes
out of this also one of the ways of
ensuring success and guarding against
failure is to ensure that as you are
experiencing things with customers we're
building small products which we test
we're not building the whole product
with building small products you may
have had this term a Minimum Viable
Product which layers alluding to the MVP
we're building a small product which we
can test and I can give it to you and
you can say okay well this thing's all
right we didn't make a ton of
assumptions we didn't build a product
with with 37 features and you then come
to me and say well actually the 37 only
three are useful right huge amount of
work only three a useful to me we've
asked you first you said just three
things useful we built the
with three features we've then because
you two in the same business you look
like each other we then produce the same
three feature product for you and so we
go well you might say well I need a
fourth feature but we can build
incrementally now if I'm not selling
anything at all or if I'm finding that
the the business model I'm building
which I'll talk more about before I move
on from this slide if the business model
I'm building shows that there are some
elements which need changing we're going
to pivot we might change the value
proposition we might change this segment
we also might change the channel that
the methodology we use to find you we
might say okay these things are working
but i'm trying to sell direct and we
should really use apple stores to sell
this product to our customers or
something else we want to ground
ourselves as much as possible and what
we know because that's managing our risk
and we might change one or more
attributes of this business model as we
as we go on now if you are running your
company on fumes if you are selling
something each month but not enough to
cover your costs you have something
called runway and your runway is limited
right your run was going to be limited
by well a couple of things the first
thing is about the money have we have
left but more importantly it's going to
be limited by the number of experiments
that you can conduct and so it Reese
tells us that pivot velocity is
crucially important because actually
doesn't matter how many months you have
what really matters is how many
experiments you can conduct if you have
a hypothesis about who your customer is
or who you're but your channel is or
what your revenue model is how you'll
make money or what your cost structure
is going to be if you have it if you
have guesses or hypotheses about those
things and you can rapidly iterate such
that you can reach the stage that you've
turned a loss-making company into a
profitable company or a loss-making
company to one which is convincing
enough to get Nancy to give you some
more money Nancy will study about
process of investing in companies in the
moment if you can convince a an investor
in some way not only that you've
discovered a way to sell one or a couple
of product
every now and again but you've
understood the market you understand
your markets needs you sell the real
pain point you found something which
solves the top three four or five needs
that you found a group of them that
looked like each other that we found
another market which is at the first
market you're going to be much more
interesting when that's your policy if
I'm right on up you're much more likely
to be interesting to a venture
capitalist so you've expanded extended
your runway okay and so another
attribute of this process of finding out
needs and experimenting and checking to
see whether our customers really really
need our product or if it's a nice to
have is is a number of customer visits
and you'll see here that that the you
know one of the core ways of ensuring
that you avoid failure enhance your
chances of success is to visit a lot of
potential customers I mean a lot of them
in an eight week period we would
classically say see if you can get to a
hundred different potential customers by
the way it'll vary all these things do
vary someone who's got a relatively low
ticket value consumer item is bound to
be having a larger number of
conversations and someone selling and
nuclear submarine but nevertheless we're
talking about a large number of
interaction and you'll see that as you
go on you've moved from a single data
point to a stage where you know more
than many of your customers or many of
your prospective customers about the
market you're operating it engineering
entrepreneurship really come together
it's it's really about being scientific
in building your company rather than
just guessing that who might buy your
product and why they might buy it and
how you might get to them all right so
I'm moving rather swiftly through this
but I sec a second point time I made to
you is and this is an area which people
focus on considerably less than than the
first point the first one is is almost
has almost become more in terms of
you build an early stage company the
second point I'm going to make is a
little bit more subtle as they only hear
that head of simon Sinek if you haven't
please write his name down and go watch
the TED talk because simon Sinek does a
talk explaining why it is that you are
more likely to buy product a versus
product B and a lot of it is to do with
something very special which is you need
to lead with why you need to lead with
why I'm going to give another analogy
because that one's not going to be clear
to you at all yet which is forwards
forwards make America great again you
know those four words right I think the
Trump campaign absolutely out marketed
the Clinton campaign which is a probably
a controversial thing to say I and by
the way I'm not going to talk about my
politics but I will just say in terms of
pure marketing went on the Clinton side
we had a situation in which there was
discipline there was policy there were
actual facts about what we might do on
the other side what do we have we had
some amazing market and if Trump ever
stood a chance of becoming elected
today's because of those four words it's
because of the inspiration and
aspiration that goes with it capturing
your your customers imagination is
incredibly important even in an
industrial procurement environment if
you are somebody who's in the industrial
procurement part of a large corporation
you're not just going to order Leslie's
new global her bald dinner under
grunting device from her because
somewhere she's announced this thing
you're you don't have a catalog you've
got the big companies catalog with you
normally fibers under grunting devices
problem you've got their products so if
you are somebody entering a market a new
need to capture your customers
imagination you need to stand out and
it's an incredibly tough thing to do but
effectively this word movement is what
comes in here you need to build a
movement particularly for consumer
products but even as I say for those
ones that live here in large
corporations you have no real advantage
as a small company over the big guys
except nimbleness and your ability to do
some of these things here now this could
be enough of a reason to capture your
customers imagination this could be
enough all by itself but it may not be
and what do I mean by this what I mean
by this is that people are often bring
products to market in the clean tech
space where they believe that it that
the fact that it's cleaner or greener is
the reason to buy and sometimes it is
sometimes even in major corporations the
fact that it's cleaner or greener is the
reason to buy their our procurement
departments in many big gob many big
companies nowadays that have a
requirement that a certain proportion of
their the products that they purchase or
indeed all the products they purchase
have to go through some kind of
sustainability criteria and they have to
match those criteria and use daniel 7
very good stead if your product is
cleaner or grading the alternatives some
consumers will buy products because it's
cleaner or green in the alternatives but
it's not always the case so the message
comes back to again one meets it's a
hypothesis you need to test it you need
to find out and you need to make sure
that your customers really believe and
understand that the movement that you
believe in is what they believe that the
inspiration that you're trying to create
is one that appeals to your market
you're you're selling propositions are
relevant to them and you know all the
rest of these things
happening on the planet I my work I
won't run through them but but the the
fact that the planet is facing a real
challenge is incredibly important to
many of us but never assume that just
because it's important to you that it's
important to the people who might buy
your products it's also worth mentioning
from a macro perspective that the fact
that these things are going on that the
fact that the regulatory environment is
getting tougher in the US the fact that
Europe and China it cares about these
things the fact that the the UN is is
now driving the agenda can be another
reason for new technologies to be
adopted in our space all right um so the
final thing I want to talk about is
developing trust and again I this is not
an area that receives a lot of attention
in our space so there's lots of talk
about the need to get out of the
building there's lots of talk about the
need to make sure that your customer
will buy a minimum minimum viable
product and need to break it down and to
find markets that you can dominate point
one is is a very heavily worked space
point2 is a more subtle one only
understood by people who really get what
it means to launch a product into a
market point number three is equally
crucial and the irony about point number
three is that it's so completely
forgotten in early-stage companies that
it becomes a thing more often than not
kills them because companies go out and
they need to do their potential
customers and there's my phone that I
should have turned off residents
yes I am lines and but number three is
incredibly important and it's incredibly
important because people will not buy
from me or from Leslie of Nancy or from
you unless they feel comfortable doing
so it's an obvious point but it's a
completely forgotten one unless they
feel comfortable doing so now this is
particularly true of major corporations
it's particularly true of corporations
who are in the business of changing
their list of suppliers what happens
when when a new startup comes on comes
along and says I've got a better
mousetrap in this operation so okay well
let's put you through a sustainability
criteria yes great you're cleaning your
greener we like that what happens when
they say we need to see a balance sheet
what happens when they say how many
customers do you have that looked like
ass how many 1400 corporations have you
sold to in the past what's the data that
you have the proves how much longer do I
have run away I'm overrun medicine I'll
wrap up I'll wrap up on what's the data
that you have the proves that be that
the claims you're making are valid in in
the cleantech well it's more often than
not the case that we're doing things in
a newer better clean away which are by
definition different from the way
they're done and it's it's it's more
often the case that the markets that
they're selling two are going to have
some level of concern about trust in the
United States for example it is very
common that a construction company isn't
going to take a new construction
material whose fault is it going to be
if this construction material from which
I have now built this new cleaner
greener construction material fails in
ten years time and you've gone bust
who's going to take the blame 25 years
from now when these engines we've
supplied no longer work because the
biofuel you're producing doesn't work so
so corporate customers is particular
element to but it's also relevant to
consume
and early stage companies find it hard
to sell to consumers when a product
comes in to market which captures the
imagination which meets their needs they
don't trust so what seated well we need
to have methodologies for developing
that trust you've heard of a company
called ikea I remember the first i went
into ikea and they had the snazzy kind
of blue and yellow branding and then the
big warehouse but they had something
else as well they had a machine in the
corner which was simulating opening and
closing this flimsy looking cheap but
attractive door on this cabinet 10,000
times a month so they could say we have
data that shows that this flimsy looking
cabinet is going to stand up to your
children whether the truth is there or
not I gotta tell you my kids have
destroyed most of the ikea cabinets that
we bought in our house within months but
nevertheless the data was there so the
trust was developed along with the rest
of it okay so um entrepreneurship clean
tech entrepreneurship they are much of a
muchness there's nothing I particularly
have to go into great detail in terms of
clean tech entrepreneurship this is very
much a kind of primer in the beginnings
of this and I hope it's useful I'm going
to hand over to Nancy right now Nancy
will talk about the other side of this
which is the view from the investor
don't forget to vote for it's great to
be back at Leslie's class and to see you
all already just got I just gotta
election report not on the top of the
ticket but a super important battle in
Florida the third largest state we just
won we the solar industry there was a
utility sponsored ballot initiative that
was sort of looked like it was pro solar
but it was actually anti-solar and it
was kind of just very misleading and it
was all set to win and I just read that
it it had to get sixty sixty percent of
the vote and I just read that it got
like fifty one percent and that was a
very last minute really
herculean effort Al Gore went down there
anyway it's it's makes me very happy and
hopefully bodes well for the rest of the
night yeah all right so it's great to be
here again and I think I have too many
slides so I'll just kind of jam through
but please ask questions at any time and
tell me when it's 20 minutes and I'll
just stop oh there we go 513 yeah so dbl
partners my firm what we spun out of
JPMorgan in 2008 and I had been a
traditional venture capitalist for many
years we are the and started our first
impact fund as part of JPMorgan in 2002
our third our second fun we raised when
we spun out in 2008 and then we excuse
me we just raised our our third fund
which is a 400 million dollar venture
fund for impact and sustainability last
year and that makes it the largest such
fund in the country so we're very
grateful to have been able to raise that
and work with companies like Tesla and
solar city and revolution foods and
Pandora and next tracker and we just
have a really great list of
entrepreneurs and what we do is we we
prove that you don't have to sacrifice
social return for financial return or
vice versa we believe the two are
inherently connected and so over the
past 11 or so years we've been
developing the proof points to show
people that you can do both and so the
field is growing incredibly fast and
becoming super popular so much so I know
I went to Stanford so I of course have a
loyalty to Stanford but I have to I was
really happy about something that
happened in September in Cambridge
Massachusetts Harvard Business School
wrote a case study on dbl and the notion
of double bottom line investing and it
was actually michael Porter's group
who's kind of the famous competitive
theory professor that did it so that was
a real thrill and now hopefully people
will learn about impact investing across
the country and at
various business schools that use the
the case method so we're on our way
we're really just trying to move forward
and and build a better case with more
and more companies to show people that
there is no sacrifice and get more
people to to do what we what we do in
terms of blending the two returns we all
we all know that we we confront very
very serious problems relating to
sustainability that's that's kind of the
bad news the good news is is that we can
do something about it and I'm going to
just focus on three sectors to today we
could talk about the others but three
sectors electricity transportation and
AG represents sixty percent or more of
greenhouse gases and so the good news is
that there's huge markets here and we
can use innovation to disrupt the the
incumbents and they do need disrupting
let me show you some of the brands here
if you if you think about GM PG&E
Monsanto John Deere these are pretty I
mean they're iconic for sure but their
iconic in some ways not so much for a
track record of innovation you know
every two or three years like Apple does
but really because they've been around a
long time some of these are even founded
in the 19th century not even the early
part of the 20th century so we we
clearly need to liven things up a bit
and get some iconic 21st century names
and in there to develop products for
21st century needs not those needs of
the 19 of the 19th or 20th century and
so that's really what venture capital is
all about so during a sort of the latter
part of the 20th century look what
happened in computers and telecom and
we've all lived through this you know
we've gone from the mainframe too many
computers to pcs to the cloud telecom
you know your grandmother has that let
you know have that land mine wireless
landline
phones to smartphones and our lives have
been improved by this I mean sometimes
and when we're addicted to our phones I
think that maybe we haven't been
improved so much but in general I think
we would all agree that life is better
for these innovations and and the
downward cost of all of these products
you know the the fact that many people
can afford to have an iPhone and in fact
through policy starting next month
although income folks that get food
stamps in this country will get an
iphone so so this is something that's
ubiquitous so what we feel is that
finally after a hundred years it's time
for these these sectors to kind of take
a take a look at the PlayBook that we've
seen in other sectors and and start to
innovate and we are seeing that we're
you know we can see that we're moving
from centralized fossil to micro grids
and distributed renewables obviously
automobiles were making that that change
started by Prius and now into full
electric and eventually autonomous drive
electric and in agriculture we're moving
from that mechanical and the green
revolution phase two more data-driven
agriculture precision agriculture as
it's called also moving much more into
low chemical inputs more organic and
sustainable agriculture and what's
happening along the way is that these
sectors are really adopting many of the
same things of themes of innovation as
the computer and the IT sectors you know
they are different in their own way
we'll talk about that but they all these
are some of the the most dominant
investment themes of our age
personalization transparency cost
reduction this is really what drives
venture investing across all sectors and
and has resulted in some really great
returns now it's coming to a
neighborhood near us in the
sustainability said the sustainability
sector and that's very very good news so
let's just take a few minutes to
to talk about those three sectors what's
is the the what do we feel the future
looks like in these industries and I'll
talk about sort of the technology pull
and the the demand a technology push
rather the demand pull so in automobiles
we really think there's a mobility
trifecta and that it's electric we're
going to electrify transportation across
the board over the next decades there's
ride-sharing and there's autonomous
drive this notion that transportation as
a service as opposed to as some asset
that sits in your driveway unused for
many hours a day and what's driving this
is cheaper less hassled you know many
folks don't really want to own a car
especially in their city in the city any
longer it's greener and it's safer you
know the data are coming out that
autonomous drive is safer so this this
really just blows apart what we think of
as the automobile industry and look at
look at the comparison of the incumbents
sort of the 20th century me and I when I
Stu this I'm not diminishing the
importance of the incumbents in the 20th
century obviously they they were huge
and they continue to play a huge role
but they're not alone anymore that's my
point is that these these companies here
these are just as important to the
future of sustainable transportation as
as our incumbents are when you look at
agriculture again it's it's it it's this
is a little earlier where we're not yet
anytime you get a Tesla that the whole
world knows about that that raises the
level of knowledge we're not quite there
with Ag but some good trends on the
technology side big data and analytics
the ability to have farmers get
information that helps them make better
decisions in terms of inputs watering
energy use that's all doable and the
good news is that it's cheap automation
the ability to use robotics and also go
indoors for agriculture lots of good
savings there the the availability of
biotech and
technology to to help on the product
side and on the demand side you've got
cheaper greener more choice and more
farmer independence we're really seeing
all the intermediaries that have existed
in agriculture begin to be displaced and
and they add costs every time that you
you take your grain from you know the
farm to the the silo to the the
distributor to the the Miller to the
end-user I mean there's just margin loss
across that whole channel and that's why
we have such a problem with farmers
staying on their lands well I think
you'll see that start to turn around as
farmers become more empowered what are
some of the and so we talked about John
Deere and Monsanto of course some of the
big names there these are some of the
names that we are looking at some of
these are investments already planet is
a company that makes microsatellites
satellites about this big that enable
you to cheaply get daily or weekly
images of land and that helps you
understand what's going on and
agriculture is a big a big application
for this new technology of cheap
frequent images because it can help you
identify crop health issues and such
Blue River is making automated farm
equipment that helps with computer
vision and robotics just helps bring
down that cost labor is one of the
highest costs on a farm so when you can
outsource some of that to a robot or use
computers to make decisions that will
improve the margins of farmers appeal
Sciences is a producer of a sort of a
wash for made out of plants and with
water that basically covers plants it
this is a food waste opportunity covers
the plant so that they don't rot as fast
and so you're able to keep avocados you
know on the shelf for weeks instead of
you know a day instead of days or you're
able to export if you're in Africa
mangoes that you could only sell to
southern if you were in Kenya you could
only sell as far north
say Italy because they would rot
otherwise if you went further north now
you can have a bigger export market for
your fruit just buy a non-toxic non-gmo
fda-approved wash really interesting
company in in Santa Barbara and then
farmers business network this is a
company we were the seed investor in
with with kleiner perkins this is this
is a cheap member service five hundred
dollars a year for farmers to
crowdsource your data that you collect
on your tractors and that they've been
collecting for decades but they never
really got their own access to the
information and so lo and behold now
they can crowdsource see where they
benchmark in a County and are they in
the 10th percentile or the 90th
percentile in terms of their yields in
terms of their costs in terms of how
many pesticides they use how much water
they use and then get get ideas for how
to if you're low how to get higher
ranked and and change your practices and
save money and also in the process of
doing this i mentioned how you're able
to get rid of some of the intermediaries
the process of aggregating this
information and it's all anonymous you
begin to see wow people are paying
vastly different prices for say corn
seeds at within the same county there's
no transparency historically and now
with big data that you you sign on to
for five hundred dollars a year you are
the sudden know that you're you're
paying a third as much as your neighbor
is and so farmers business network is
able to identify that that problem and
then just sell you the the seeds
directly at that lower price so lots of
ways to monetize the value and and also
improve the margins of farmers which
will be necessary if we are to feed you
know the ever-growing world that we live
in but just some things just to show you
how these are the points that farmers
business network has think they have
about 12 million acres so far they're
only about two years old and
they will give you the seeding rates
they'll give you the crop intensity
what's growing where it's just a very
easy and easy to access us in
information that farmers use iPads to to
receive and then all but the the Blue
River one yeah so the future of energy
of course we we believe it relies on the
electrification of transportation which
we already covered but it's no good to
electrify vehicles if we don't green the
grid I mean no one's going to be super
excited you know 10 years from now to
have all these electric cars if we're
still running our grid on coal so we
need distributed renewables we need
storage bringing that to the party makes
a huge difference microgrids the ability
to pull your power from the rooftop
solar or the grid or the storage in in
your garage based on price signals and
based on grid strength that's really
coming sooner than you think and that
makes every building really its own
virtual power plant and you can save a
lot of energy and and develop clean
energy and also save money in this which
is which is going to be very appealing
and then demand response you layered
that on say you have all these ways to
control where your power is coming from
and then you layer on well you know when
it's 100 degrees out and everyone's got
their air conditioners on and you're not
supposed to use the grid as a result so
you're drawing off of your solar panels
why not you know just automatically
reduce your air conditioning for for the
period of the day that you're not really
in the house or or whatever so that's
that's all we've we've seen demand
response gen 1 but we're moving into gen
2 with demand response connected to
storage and and so are much more
powerful that way and of course this is
all driven by the need for cheaper
greener more choice consumer choice is a
huge driver we don't want to just be
told what our electricity is by our
utility anymore Mesa
people do which is fine but grow a
growing number don't more reliability
and more functionality like I just
described to you that scenario is going
to be very powerful I'm just going to
skip through the next what the next few
slides this is the infamous or famous
depending on your point of view duck
curve where if we have so much solar
during them on a grid during the middle
of day we have no no real load and then
when everyone goes home and turns on
their lights when the Sun Goes Down we
have this amazingly high load and so
this is this is something that utilities
and policy makers you know really focus
on a neat to fix well it's it's it's
fixable with solar and storage and
renewables and micro grids you can
really that blue line instead of having
all this choppiness you can smooth your
your load buy by introducing this these
technologies so that's a huge plus
you're seeing a lot of storage projects
going in utility-scale both in terms of
number of installations a number of
megawatts they're going to be iconic
companies that really learn how to
connect the distributed assets that is
everyone's rooftop with solar and turn
that into a generation asset we have a
company called advanced micro grid
solutions that is developing these micro
these virtual power plants I was telling
you about already has 90 megawatts of
contracts with socal edison and is just
signed a deal with a Vesco a huge real
estate conglomerate back east these are
kind of the names you're going to be
hearing a lot more about going forward
and then finally on energy this is a
deal that we did in Africa you know
there are there 1.3 billion people on
this planet they don't even have
electricity and and half of those are in
sub-saharan Africa and so they use they
use kerosene lamps which are both
unhealthy and bad for the planet and so
for about the same price
these rural areas you're able to have a
small panel at a small battery and very
efficient lamps and TVs and bring
electricity to these homes for the first
time at about the same price that you
pay for kerosene and also be able to pay
with your mobile phone and and have a
loan product so you don't have to buy it
all at once this is happening this this
company off-grid electric which has some
people here in San Francisco most people
in Tanzania and now other countries like
Rwanda and West Africa these there are
hundreds of thousands of homes that have
already been converted and this is just
the beginning this is such this is kind
of one of the highest impact you can
have I believe is is to prevent a
centralized fossil-based grid from being
built in areas that are that are grid
free right now and at the same time
allow families to move into the middle
class by giving them light and
affordable energy clean energy this is
one of the the benefits of my job I mean
there's all kinds of risks and problems
we face on a daily basis but because
this is so important when you do
important things you get to go to pretty
high level meetings and while we're all
focused on the election today which and
we've been very involved in a lot of
policies it here in our country and in
our state this is of interest to the
Pope and so on saturday i'm actually
going to the Vatican to talk about this
company and in the off-grid opportunity
with Cardinal Turkson and the Pope Pope
Francis one of the days its sudden it's
starts Sunday night Monday Tuesday
Wednesday he's going to be there with us
for half a day I know I know like all
those times when we have headaches this
this uh and and we worry about all of
our companies this kind of is this one
of the fun things you get to do this is
just more visuals on their products and
and such so the really what's happening
is that
when we started in the two thousand
there wasn't that much to invest in you
know we had we had power light and Tesla
and solar city but the good news today
is is that there's so much to invest in
and and Rex is was really helpful and
kind of helping you understand how how
to position what you're doing and and
really focus on on narrowing your your
opportunities so as to increase the
chances of success but it despite the
same time by the same token we have to
diversify you know financial investors
need diversification and now we just
have an abundance of things to invest in
so i think i'm going to stop there i
have a whole policy thing but we can we
can get into that and the the QA so
thank you very much you want us to sit
here oh I'll take the end one here and
well we'll ask we've got about 15
minutes until we're formally done if you
and I think you have to run right away
so we better be really fast about this
first I guess before I go to the written
in questions is there a single burning
question there that just has to be asked
I see right away yes so about your
breakdown of energy transportation
agriculture the energy in the
transportation I agree that I think
that's a lot of what people are thinking
I was really surprised in your
agriculture when I think about
agriculture and climate change I think
about issues around resilience yields
irrigation issues and water
accessibility and I didn't see that as
any of the full factors in your yet know
it's there it's just that it's very hard
to make money and a company that's just
doing one input because that's not how
farmers work you know they work with all
inputs and so and usually they use too
much of everything that's kind of
a gross generalization but if you really
look at what's happening they use to
they plant too many seeds they use too
much fertilizer they use too much
pesticides they use too much water and
so the data is kind of the Trojan horse
it's once you get in the door and you
show farmers what they're doing and how
they could improve then they begin to
begin to kind of deconstruct and allow
farmers to use less of everything and so
that's that's how you get because you're
measuring it you can't really make a
compelling case for a farmer until
you've measured and shown them that
they're over watering or they're they're
growing a crop in an area that really
isn't suited for it and they should
switch to something else so so it's a
mean organic we do a lot of food
investing and organic is a big part of
our investment thesis we have a organic
cold-pressed juice appliance company
that totally is driven by organic
agriculture but if you look at the
numbers the the real carbon is produced
in row crops and in mega-farms and so if
all you do is at the edges work with the
organic farmers you're you're not going
to move the needle you need to do both I
guess so just one of the simplest ones
and I think you've answered it but I
want to make sure we get it all milk out
what are some of the key success factors
you look for in a clean tech startup so
let's say you're sitting out here with a
phenomenal idea what well I think Rex
really covered a lot of that and in
terms of the focus and and and defining
your market you know I think we look at
it's really the same as other other
startups although we will look at
regulatory trends and we don't we don't
ding you because you have a regulatory
issue because that kind of goes with the
territory but if we don't feel we can
make any progress in terms of making
sure regulatory themes are consistent
with business success then that's
something that we would have trouble
with so what we look for is tenacity and
and nimbleness as you say
and the ability to move move regular
regulations move markets displace
incumbents really has to do with the
team and they experience I mean
obviously we want a defendable
defensible IP position we want big
markets that are willing to change but
that's that kind of is any deal but i
would say in clean tech deals you really
do need people that are willing to take
on huge incumbents and know how to do it
in a sophisticated way and also move
regulations as well so you're going into
two of my own question so kind yes if I
jump in yeah so we could be kind of
interesting to test this with you Nazis
so in the acne to get at least at least
in you know on my watch what we do to
try and boil down much what your seconds
I think you cut it all is we would say
the 3 t's team technology traction and
actually we converted the third t into
market because most of the companies
that we work worked with work with our
very early stage and have no traction so
traction potential or the market so so
but in that order more or less and much
of what I spoke about today was to do
with the market side and market
definition and the domination of the
market and penetration of the market saw
but the interesting thing is that in
talking to a lot of venture capitalists
it number one thing that we always get
back is dead start with the team because
if the technology is me do cover the
team's great the team will figure it out
if them if they haven't got much
traction but the team's great then then
they'll figure it out so interesting to
get your perspective absolutely I mean
obviously do you always like to have an
a on both the team and the the product
but you know in some ways I'd rather
have an a-minus team and a b-minus
product than vice versa because you
can't always pivot and not always I mean
sometimes you just won't succeed but but
with the nimble a strong team you can
take something that isn't perfect and
turn it into something that will be
viable so my own list of what I was
wondering if you guys would pick between
and I think we've heard it is I add so
what's most important to you technology
team commit
I p market fit collaborations other I'm
here in team yeah because the team kind
of results in all those other things
coming into place anyway yeah and it's
what it's worth just mentioning I think
I said it but you know there's a huge
focus particularly i think in people who
are kind of arriving in Silicon Valley
to be very protective of the IP and to
make sure that they don't tell anyone
about what they've got this thing and
have been to stealth mode for Evan of
course there's value in in being a
stealth mode for some period time but
it's probably it's probably another
preciousness many of the companies that
succeed succeed because they're open
because they get lots of advice from
lots of good people because they use
silicon valley they use the resources
that are out there they use people like
Nancy they go and they talk to avenge
caplets and frankly if your IP is so
thin that by describing it to somebody
they could just steal the whole thing
you probably haven't got a company
anyway there you go another one that you
touched on was what's the so here's my
question related to what's the relative
importance of policy and entrepreneurial
technology in addressing climate change
and what's important about how policy
and technical arenas interact it's very
I mean it's essential I mean I I have
sort of another trifecta in addition to
the mobility trifecta which is it takes
innovation or technology it takes policy
and it takes capital I mean that's kind
of the the world that we live in and
that we navigate through and that
entrepreneurs do as well and so it's not
that you I me and policy is not static I
mean and and the results I just showed
you or told you about in Florida no one
would have predicted that you know six
months ago so it's not like you can get
it right and then just check off that
box it has to be part of your DNA you
have to end and like Lyndon rive the CEO
of SolarCity I mean he didn't believe
how many people he had to hire very
early on in that company to deal with
all of the different states
environmental and
metering laws and and I didn't you know
I sit wow we have so many government
affairs people and which is unusual most
I mean then that's not something that
you hire in a startup company but in
this industry especially in the solar in
the wind industry's it's very very
important so you know you you can use
trade associations and and all of that
but when it comes down to it in
uncharted territory which is what this
is the leading market players will set
the policy the dialogue it's it's gross
what you're saying that we're living in
this world where startups have to get
involved in policy in the way but I mean
we have many many instances of this kind
of thing and I just occur see one of
them is one of the fans of the cleantech
open and she was involved in an electric
bus company you may know the company
right era indeed it so a lot of marks
work was a about going to Congress
seeing if there were some kind of if
there are means to get governments of
the stations to to get the demand pull
from municipalities so a lot of that but
also a lot of it was to do with the fact
that you know when you are putting a big
draw on the grid in the middle of the
day to recharge an electric bus that the
cost of so doing it just because of the
way that the tariffs work the more you
use the cost doesn't go up by small
amount that certainly doesn't go up in a
linear fashion with the amount you're
using it you have an exponential leap in
the amount you have to pay for for
energy so here to go to the Public
Utilities Commission the PUC here in
California and actually talk about the
issue that we could never have electric
buses you could never have that
replacement take place if there weren't
some way of changing those tariffs it's
it's a bizarre thing for a set up to
have to take on but as you as you say
the the leading companies then change
the regulatory environment of everybody
yeah that's wild um what are your
thoughts on Bill Gates breakthrough
Energy Coalition will it really bring
breakthrough technologies to the
forefront of the clean tech revolution
or will there really be a huge financial
gap between innovation and funding
bringing it to scale well you know I I
feel we needed all you well I am not in
a position to invest in things that are
going to take 20 or 30
years to to fruition to come to fruition
if family off mega family offices want
to do that I say more power to them I my
feeling is is that he's going to do both
I mean and I'm not that I'm directly
involved but what I've heard is that
they're going to you know go for some
real long long odds kinds of investments
but also do some that are nearer term
and so I do think it's important to to
make sure that we we have a healthy
ecosystem that creates companies that
can help now as opposed to 10 years from
now having said that you know it's a
free country if people want to do both
you know I think I think that's great
and there's another program called so
the criteria for the coalition are those
announced also that the Paris summit
which is this mission innovation there's
another program which launched in the UK
called the apollo global program and
they're all very similar to each other
polyglot global wants to get countries
devoting point zero two percent of our
gdp I think it is to solving these big
problems they all have a place I mean we
talked today about the need for
commercial traction if you have a
product which is not interesting to a
particular market then you have a you
have a problem but on the other hand if
you can if you can find a source of
funding which is non-commercial then
other things can happen so one of the
cool things here we have in the u.s. is
arpa-e the Advanced Research Projects
Agency foot for energy and what they do
is they fund the kinds of things that
Nancy probably wouldn't fund they're
going to try they they come in where I
come in right after them or they go are
you coming out and because they've taken
the technology risk and then we're now
moving into a phase where it comes back
to the team and other things as well I
think every year in the cleantech open I
used to look at sea five to ten really
kind of wild way out there companies
that had something which if they could
raise 10 or 15 or
20 or sometimes more million dollars
then the technology could change the
planet but who was going to ever find
that 10 or 15 or or 50 million dollars
well now there are ways of those things
happening and then they can enter the
the mainstream venture capital and
capital markets funding mechanisms how
could that mean the only thing I would
say is that we we shouldn't let the
perfect be the enemy of the good because
we do have a time clock ticking and we
can't take you know another 100 years to
figure this out so you know we need to
make sure we support the solar panels
and the wind and the electric cars that
we have today and make sure they
proliferate as we then reinvest for
next-gen functionality that's another
angle on the how patient dis capital
have to be in the clean tech space it's
like perhaps some patients but very
urgent right yeah well I mean we do have
a sense of urgency on the other hand
venture as an asset class is you know
most funds are ten years and so you do
have more you know you're not investing
in stocks that you know you have to
unload on a weekly basis so yeah that's
the good news so you know I think that
it it really you know you have an
investment period in a fund for the
first three to five years and then you
have kind of use years four through nine
to kind of start harvesting everything
and then you've also got some laggards
and kind of you you work those out over
a longer period of time so I mean that's
that's the model of our business and you
know it it's not always perfect but it
works pretty well the family offices
that don't answer to their and you know
are their own investors so I mean I have
tons of investors that I need to answer
to and I need you know I've got a
pension fund you know I'm not going to
you know I need to make money for those
those investors so but if you're a
family office you you can have you have
more freedom you you have a long a
longer time frame if you want and and so
you're able to kind of play on the edges
a little more I think it's just worth
mentioning and how special dbl is you
know I mean Nancy anything they've done
an amazing job finding a space which is
not really quite flavor of the month
anymore you know I mean although these
things go in waves there were a lot of
venture capital firms in that kind of
2005-2006 era including some very big
name VC firms that you know you've all
heard of who are no longer investing in
this space and Nancy by investing the
likes of SolarCity and tassel and so
forth an extraordinary job of picking
some great winners it's also worth
mentioning that they've done a great job
because they're managing to get returns
in the traditional venture capital sense
you know I was on a panel with another
VC saying if you look at our return on
capital you know the capital deployed
and then the returned we've got over
time it's been great the problem is that
you know VC funds are typically have
this kind of time limited period that
you know they need to get the return on
capital within a much shorter space than
say 20 years so the IRR the internal
rate of return is the measure by which
they are judged and it's it's pretty
rare for a VC firm in this space
investing in agriculture and the like to
manage to make those going to return so
they're very special ppl other thank you
thanks in fact there were some questions
on the double bottom line do all of your
investors believe in that every single
time yes on a certain level I say some
are passionate about it and some are as
long as I make money I'm good with the
double bottom line so I mean it but
that's good because we bring people in
and and they learn more about it and
then there are people that are just
passionate and they helped build the
field so I think it's really important
to have a diversity of investors and and
to be able to it makes our job you know
we have to please everyone and so it you
know it's not enough just to you know
have a mission you have to back that up
with the results that allow you then to
scale we wouldn't have a four hundred
million dollar fund if we weren't being
responsive to the people that want to
make money and make a difference
fantastic I saw an urgent question yes
kind of put together the last question a
few things from the presentation and I
really enjoyed the framing of you know
we
SI models been applied to the technology
in software etc and we've had all these
incredible companies and now we're
flying into these new fields these you
know that three ones brought up but I'm
short by the difference between you know
assault software or a nap and a you know
energy transportation and agriculture is
capital intensity and so you know as
this we've kind of started talking you
know there's this time problem and and I
just add you've got another way to look
at that same dimension is using a lot of
money and instead of play the devil's
advocate a little bit r is bc as an
asset class large enough or other fun
size is large enough given the need for
portfolio diversification to really
handle the pink checker or should we be
looking elsewhere to different financing
well you know you can solve the problem
of capital intensity by the way you
manage your portfolio you know if we've
had all Tesla's in our first fund even
though you know turned out to be you
know a grand slam and then some you know
we couldn't you know we were a 75
million dollar fund there's no way we
could have had you know 12 companies in
the portfolio that needed as much cash
as Tesla did so you can so you make sure
you invest in companies you have a mix
some that don't require you know we had
a eat we had a smart meter software
company that we sold to Siemens oh yeah
that didn't make require as much money
but when you win in capital intensive
investments you make a huge amount
because they are by definition they're
very significant companies so you don't
need you don't need to have a whole
portfolio of them and so a lot of what
we're trying to do is just is balanced
and make sure that we you know we're
capturing the opportunity but not not
overextending ourselves and then the
second thing you do is you get
syndicates where you're not writing the
only check your you're in there with
other other groups that are in for the
first and second and third round and
however many it takes before you sell
the company or it goes public and so
that's a way to to mitigate the risk is
to have
wrong deep-pocketed investors like in
the the farm company that we did farmers
business network kleiner and dbl in the
beginning and then Google Ventures came
in and then we just did around with the
Campbell's Soup venture arm so these are
all great groups that add lots of value
but they also you know they're in for
the long haul and they have that deep
pockets to help through those those
periods of growth and since the to add
to that you know the fact is that
venture capital the venture capital
model is relevant for a number of
reasons one of them is that you have the
big brains and the access to diligence
and the the kinds of things that can
lead around where cash may come in and
that's just mention one strategic
investor in a campbell soup or another
in a major deep-pocketed investor that
may be coming in for different reasons
than IRR which has at a time frame
attached to it they may be coming up a
whole series of different reasons
because they have a strategic reason
reason to invest it's also worth
mentioning that there are other forms of
capital that come in when a venture
capitalist is involved for example when
you've got something you can kick you
might be able to get debt financing
because there's an asset that you can
use as collateral it's not always the
case there's a lot of inventory
particular when it's experimental has no
real value and the and the banks don't
want to put their money behind something
which has no value you know if the
company were to fail look at solyndra
when they failed those tubes weren't
actually worth anything but nevertheless
there are plenty of things that you buy
particularly when it comes to buying
robots or buying raw materials or buying
equipment for manufacturing that that
have a value outside you know the
company itself and they can be financed
separately any other burning questions
out here
she the one come peaceful it up now it's
indoor sorry what we're having trouble
hearing you we got this thing going up
and you were an you very quiet try to
yell sorry I stand up that's why a
little about the portfolio of dbl and
Maggie your companies tend to be all
energy and climate face however there's
one that stood out in that case was
candor I was wondering how do you be
able to side you must be adored how that
fed ya don't well yeah we're not all
sustainability you're asking about kind
of what do we say decide to invest in it
we have a you know a core commitment to
sustainability and so maybe sixty
percent but we also invested in Pandora
we invested in the Mews which is a
career building site for Millennials
it's it's really taking off we're in the
real real which is a online luxury
consignment site headquartered up in San
Francisco that's also doing extremely
well so we the reason we do that is a
for financial returns to diversify and
when solar was in the tank you know
digital music was was not and then when
digital music wasn't it the tank Fuller
was not so that that worked out well but
we also want to prove that impact lives
in any company and while it's obvious
why Tesla has social impact or SolarCity
it isn't as obvious for Pandora and so
what we do in those companies is we work
to bring out a social impact and in the
case of Pandora we worked we had a whole
community engagement program with them
where they they taught music they still
do in a low-income school where there
was no music budget and the employees
many musicians obviously work at Pandora
they loved interacting with kids who
didn't have any music courses in the
schools they learned a lot about how
kids relate to music so it was kind of a
win-win that bill gave them more local
political capital so in those early days
when they had to fight the record
industry for the right digital for the
right royalty structure they were able
to ask the mayor of Oakland you know
to help them connect with a congressman
that actually helped write the digital
music copyright act and that Mayor you
know he didn't know anything about
digital music he was not a Pandora
listener but he had heard about how
Pandora taught music at at one of his
schools and you said wow you guys are
giving back and what can I do to help
you so a lot of times you build
political or community capital by by by
engaging with a broader set of
stakeholders and while it doesn't always
work those kinds of stories we tell all
of you know there are many of them where
you kind of did something just to kind
of do the right thing and then it ended
up helping you in fact the CEO of
Pandora the time said you know I never
realized when we've taught music down by
the Oakland Coliseum that would help us
on Capitol Hill and so that's kind of a
good sense sound bites for for impact
and so that's why we do it for because
we love entrepreneurs of all stripes and
we want diversification but we also want
to show people you know maybe you you
don't like electric cars maybe you don't
want to go work at Tesla maybe you're
really a musician and you want to have
impact we do that to show you that you
know you can have impact even though
what you're doing isn't obviously impact
you